[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dan arlovski gets paid the big money to
answer questions like that espn
will have its mega cast production they
got the ravens in titans wild card game
at one eastern on sunday dan and the
rest of the nfl live crew
and uh you can check that out the
traditional telecast will be on espn on
abc
do you think that this is a we'll get
back to you at some
point eric bienemy or the texans aren't
interested in interviewing the chief's
offensive coordinator
yeah i would imagine that they're not
interested which is moronic
you know the fact that they they should
have
hired him after that playoff debacle
last year they should have said no we're
done with bill o'brien
the enemy come in so you know i don't
think like that the texans job is
that much about desean i mean it's
really get out of the way
he's such a special player it's more so
like can you find a way to rebuild the
roster with absolutely no assets
that's the biggest challenge so it's
like the fact that they haven't
interviewed eric the enemy or that he's
not at the top of their list
is just a very small kind of
uh viewpoint into how dysfunctional
the houston texans are are run right now
yeah i don't think it's a great job and
if you were going to rank these jobs
where would you start with number one
opening the chargers
easily mainly because the chargers have
a general manager that's proven
it's not just i mean the fact that
herbert's there is amazing
but telesco's put together a really good
roster and
i think that's like one of the hardest
things to do in the nfl is find really
good
consistent general managers second um
you know i know everyone points to the
jags because they have the number one
pick
but i would be a little bit hesitant
hearing shad khan come out and say he
wants some form of roster control
you know like and you don't know who the
general manager is there
if you look at the jets job at least i
know at least i have
one year of joe douglas as the guy
and go okay he had three really good
picks in his first draft or at least
two that looked really good with mims
and bechten
some third rounders had some promise so
like i've got a guy that's got
15 plus years in baltimore as a gen as a
front office guy
who we know baltimore is fantastic and i
have proof that like
he can draft good good players and
they've got so many picks
moving forward i i could sit here and
tell in in my opinion say
i think the jets job is better than the
jags because of the guy
taking the pics yeah i've always said
when people go oh they got all these
draft picks and i say
who's drafting who's who's using those
picks
the browns had all these picks all these
years and they didn't do well so
baltimore makes use of whatever picks
they have better than anybody does
what is just um oh you know what let me
ask you this question uh because i've
asked this to daniel jeremiah
that you could have trevor lawrence or
you could have justin herbert right now
um i would say justin herbert
and that's a big jump for me yeah um
because
i was a huge trevor lawrence fan and i
still am
but the two things are i think the thing
that stands out the most to me
is when herbert's back was against the
wall
and he really had to like kind of take
over games this year
he did like he took over games i
understand the offensive line wasn't
great
and some receivers were down and he
still played really well
as much as i love trevor lawrence and as
much as i don't like the scheme that he
played in at clemson and that they were
kind of okay talent wise this year he
didn't he didn't rise up
when his back was against the wall and
that would be something that i have to
figure out
why that was the case the last three
times
he's played in those big games when the
team across from him was pretty darn
good
and he had to become like the dude the
difference maker
he didn't do it and um that's a little
bit that gives me pause
but if you look at justin fields now
with what he did
how he played got you know hit pretty
hard the toughness there had some great
deep throws over the middle
and now you have the national title game
is there a way that he could somehow
come out of this
as the quarterback in the draft
oh yeah absolutely i'd say two two ways
why two
or reasons why if if urban mark takes
the jacksonville job
i could absolutely see him liking justin
fields
and then two if you go out and whoop up
on nick saban's defense
that's a big deal to the nfl i mean nfl
coaches
value and evaluators value nick saban as
a coach
if you go out and whoop venables and
whoop nick saban
you can absolutely see him jumping
trevor lawrence
if you were the jets what would you do
so if i'm the jets and i sit there and i
go you know what i think justin fields
or zack wilson is as good as sam darnold
or in three years is gonna be as good as
sam darnold
i take one of those young quarterbacks
because i'm reset in the financial clock
you know as a quarterback where if you
decide
sam is going to be an exponentially
better player
fine but you got one year to figure that
out because it's
after next year you've got to make the
decision on the fifth year for him and
then he starts becoming expensive
and so that's the challenge for joe
douglas is trying to figure out
where where are those quarterbacks inc
and i love sam
but just the financial freedom that you
get drafting one of those two
quarterbacks so if you think they're
just as good
and they're going to be just as good in
the next three years you don't see this
big gap between them and sam
you take either zach wilson or justin
fields
do the dolphins have to do their due
diligence with the number three pick
overall
and look at a quarterback absolutely not
um the the dolphins are right on pace
with where they should be when it comes
to rebuilding their roster
here's the thing dan like the last two
years they took a bunch of assets
and allocated them to the defensive side
of the ball both in free agency and the
draft and they hit
a bunch that's why they were a good
football team this year
they got to do the same thing on the
offensive side this year
you know tua is not a recess style
of freestyle type of quarterback he's an
executor
he's drew brees but with a little bit
more athleticism
so how do we make sure like here's the
thing what's the number one
physical asset i don't care what the
quarterback looks like the number one
physical asset
can you be nfl accurate tua can be nfl
accurate
you can't just like cross your fingers
and hope that somebody becomes that and
so
they got to draft either an offensive
lineman or an offensive tackle and
offensive guard with the number three
pick my guess is it's going to be pene
sewell
draft that just like the saints did the
saints in the last 10 years
of their drafts in the first two rounds
took
seven offensive linemen they took two
wide receivers
like they built their team to protect
the quarterback
and then they got good players around
them that's what they need to do with
tua
build the offensive line protect him get
in him
get him in an offense that is similar to
what drew has been
in sean payton and two we will be a
great player
but just getting another quarterback is
not the answer he's dan orlowski espn
nfl live
analyst the browns without kevin
stefanski so you don't have your head
coach and you don't have your play
caller
how do you try to substitute what what
can be done because we've seen a
different baker mayfield here
kind of getting used to that cadence and
play calling and understanding what your
team's identity is here
and now you go into this game against
the steelers so
what do the browns do yeah one of the
the strengths of kevin stefanski is his
his opening script
the first 15 20 plays of a game he
scripts out and so people know like
coaches grind tape all week and they
figure out okay defenses
they like to play soft early on so we'll
get easy completions or
they blitz us so we gotta have blitz
answers or they'll play a ton of man so
we got to take shots downfield like
that's what the opening script is about
is figuring out how defenses want to
start games
and then attacking that well we know
that kevin stefanski's
really got one quarter to impact this
football game because after your first
two drives as an offense
defenses start to figure out what you're
doing and change
so then you are in that constant
changing mode stefanski want to be there
quarters two three and four to figure
that out
so we know he's got one quarter to
really get his finger
fingerprints and stamp his imprint on
this game
if i'm kevin stefanski the only way i
think we can win this game is we get out
14
nothing if we get to the end of the
first quarter up three nothing we can't
win
because the steelers have an advantage
then because of that change in him not
being there
i'm emptying the bag in the first
quarter i'm coming out
incredibly aggressive and whatever trick
plays
or gimmick plays that i think we've got
that we execute well that we've
practiced all season
they're getting used and trying to
figure out a way to jump out
14 nothing because if they jump out 14
nothing because of that
then they got a chance okay they can
pound the run they can be aggressive at
their defensive line
that's their only shot because the one
of the main
changes this year as we know is
stefanski but he's been able to
impact the game on on a first through
fourth quarter basis he won't do that
this week
he knows he's got 15 minutes make him
count
got an upset this weekend
oh man um do i think that the
chicago bears can beat the saints i do
um if i'm the chicago bears i'm doing
the same exact game plan
that the philadelphia eagles use with
jalen hurts
you know mitchell trubisky is going to
have eight plus runs in this game if i'm
them
because they play so much man coverage
basically it becomes
one-on-one out in the open field with
mitchell and someone else
and he's athletic enough to make guys
miss and so i i think that
if they can kind of allow him to be an
athlete a ton which they've done here
recently
i could see that happening um could i
see tennessee beating balt
beat in baltimore i could you know if if
especially early on those two receivers
aj brown and corey davis make some
impact and get
kind of the coverage back derek henry
here's the thing like i i i used to be
with gary kubiak and when we were with
coobs
and we were playing against the defense
that had two really good cover corners
coops would say all the time we're gonna
make the cover corners tackle early in
this game we're gonna find out if those
guys want to tackle or they just want to
cover
and i could see arthur smith starting
this game for tennessee and going all
right
marcus peters and and marlon humphrey
we're gonna find if you guys want tackle
and if you don't game is over
well wait wait how does that work though
dan that yeah like
how does the defensive back not tackle
it's a want to i mean tackling 260
pounds is a want to
you know it's and in the run game dan
like
you know run game is always math you
know and and there's always going to be
one person that's left over and then as
an offense your job is to figure out how
to find
who that one person is you can scheme
things up there all right corner
you're going to be the one guy and you
go derek that that's your guy
and you know i've never had to tackle
260 pounds i'm thankful but like
that that's how you do it you scheme up
to be okay we're not gonna block that
guy that's the tailbacks
and corners are gonna have to come up
and and dude it's a physical commitment
to go like all right i'm putting my face
on this dude
and uh especially early on in football
games man we used to do it
like here's an example um we would do it
with a guy like antonio cromartie crowe
was
incredible at coverage we would run at
him early in games on purpose
even if the play wasn't successful and
the back would be like all right that's
my guy and it would be this violent
collision
and you would watch it and be like okay
one was their impact
you know like was their impact and and
two does it affect his ability to cover
and three if he's not gonna tackle he's
gonna see that all game long
i'm wondering about drew brees it's hard
for
you guys to leave the game um you know
when you win
you know john elway couldn't play
anymore so he wins the super bowl he was
able to walk away
uh peyton manning couldn't play anymore
he's able to walk away
i can't imagine you know drew brees
let's say he would lose to the bears
is he more likely than to want to come
back because
you just went out in the first round or
he's got the nbc job
yeah i think he's more than likely just
to walk away after a great career i
think
he's he could be honest with himself
that he's still good but he's
good enough to really kind of um
you know be the dominant quarterback
that he's been for a long time i also
there's the reality that
there's 77 million over the cap next
year can they afford drew
can they afford paying him 25 or 30
million dollars but also
afford the people that are gonna needed
to be around him to play well
so i think at the end of the day he's a
hall of famer he's in the conversation
for one of the greatest ever
um but i don't think especially with the
injury this year like
i think that drew is is content to walk
away
and knowing he's got something else and
he's joining a different team
makes it a little bit easier who gives
the rams a better chance to upset
seattle
as far as quarterbacking goes i don't
know if you've ever broken your thumb
but yeah i've done it twice i've done
exactly what goff has done
um i've done it in college or high
school once in the nfl once one time i
came back in like two weeks um and then
one time
post surgery i came back in five weeks
that was the nfl time
uh jared goff i would be shocked if he
doesn't play
this is like golf gives them a way
better chance to win the football game
than walford does a way better chance
and if goff feels good especially early
on
i think the rams win the game because i
don't think beating seattle is i think
it's first team to 20 points
right and if you watch those two games
back
i actually texted jared because i know
him and uh
i just sent him a note and i said find
your freaking checkdown
because there's eight game eight times
that the check down is wide open and he
just won't throw it
trying to do something else and he
responded back to me hahaha
um so i think he gets the point um so
you think he's playing
i think he's playing i i i haven't i
haven't asked him that question i try to
kind of
like respect that stuff well if you're
saying to him your check down
if you're not talking about next year
like you're talking
about this weekend yeah we're talking
about this weekend yeah i i'm
anticipating he's playing because i've
had that injury and i
and i kind of know the surgery that he
had and and know that you can come back
in two weeks from it so
he gives them the best chance um and i i
as of today and i don't think i'll
change i think that they win the game i
think
the rams win the game uh let me see if i
had anything else for you
what's in the fridge by the way anything
good
um i mean a lot of kid stuff just
because we got so many stinking kids but
uh leftover tacos from last night
leftover tacos are glorious don't you
have uh do you have triplets
i have triplets you have nine-year-old
boys that are psychos and then my
daughter's five
yeah so like now i'm finding out you
know i've had
i have so many friends that have some
kids that are older than me and they
used to always talk to me about you
sports
and i'd be like you guys are idiots with
you sports like stop spending all this
money to
have your kid do a smith board
one of my sons is super into lacrosse
and we live in westport and it's a big
deal around here
so like i get these emails and like hey
here's the six
this six um clinic it's 350
and i'm like what so uh yeah that that's
the thing with our boys right now did
you ever mix up the triplets
oh all the time yeah because two of them
are identical um
and so is there a chance that you have
mixed them up
and that you might be calling one by the
wrong name
100 there's been multiple moments
where i'll be like madden will you stop
doing that
and like i'm screaming for 15 seconds
like madden stop and hunter will look
back at me and be like
i'm hunter
yeah i do it all the time
uh hey great to have you on again and uh
good luck this weekend have fun and
thanks for joining us
my pleasure man thank you that's dan
orlowski of the mothership
they've got they got i think the game of
the weekend because you got uh the
titans against the ravens wild card
weekend that's at one eastern
on sunday uh the traditional telecast
will be on espn and abc